i want to start with congratulations on
the sequel uh you did a fantastic job i
know fans are gonna love it um and i
think the first thing they're gonna ask
when they finish the movie is um is that
guy who directed sonic 2 coming back for
sonic 3.
uh i'm having a blast i love this cast i
love his crew we have so much fun making
these movies i think you can tell with
the actors jim carrey's having the time
of his life playing robotnik so nothing
would make me happier i'm not officially
involved with any of the additional
films yet but i'm so proud of this movie
i'm so proud of the first movie so
excited for fans to see it um so yeah
it's it's they really are uh incredible
movies to make
i think a lot of people don't realize
what you actually have to do on this
movie because you are directing live
action you're directing animation you're
doing these big action set pieces like
there's so many different mediums that
you're pulling together into one
finished product what ended up being the
most real pain in the ass thing to get
right on this one in terms of all the
different things i mean it really was uh
i mean just the scope of it but that was
also the best part of it i mean it was
such such a big movie it does have so
many visual effects so many big
sequences but yeah having a having a
background in visual effects and i
started my career as a character
animator it's really what i love and
getting to work with a live action sort
of cast and actors like jim carrey and
to kind of like fuse that with with
animation it's just i mean it's a dream
come true i mean these these movies are
such a delight to work on uh and so i
feel very fortunate to be uh to be
entrusted with a character like sonic
and a universe like sonic that allows
for us to just do these just big fun uh
action-packed movies
uh i spoke to jim earlier and he told me
that like when he goes to set he will
have tons of alts in his back pocket
ready to do ready to go so what is it
actually like in the editing room when
you have to pick from like five awesome
jim carrey moments for and you have to
whittle it down to one it's the best
problem to have i mean really it's like
and it is hard because what you laughed
at uh for the last couple weeks suddenly
you look at that other alt and like oh
that's that's really funny too and it's
like
it can be very challenging to pick a
favor because they're all hilarious jim
works so hard on robotnik he brings so
many ideas to set every every day and
and and we film as much as we can so
that we do have all those great options
when we're editing but um yeah it is at
the end of the day a wonderful problem
to have that we have so much jim carrey
to work with
with knuckles voice with idris he who is
fantastic as knuckles um how did you
discover or how did you figure out the
actual voice you know what i mean like
the way he would
deliver his lines and stuff like that uh
it was just workshopping in some of the
earlier sessions it was just trying
things uh putting them up against the
cut seeing how they they felt and then
idris of course had his own opinion kind
of on on what he thought and and but
yeah it just really took a little
dialing in fortunately we had lots of of
previz and early sort of animation that
we could kind of take the voice put it
up against the picture watch it talk
about it and then just kind of dial it
in
sometimes on movies you know things
change radically during the filming
process and in the editing room was this
the case on this film did you start off
making something like how did it change
while you were making the film was it
ever a completely different story you
know was it you know what i mean no i'm
actually very proud to say that we
really aside from some some some minor
adjustments here and there i mean we
didn't have any any reshoots on the film
it was just i think we had a really
strong story from the start and a lot of
it was really just about trying to
tighten it up as much as possible make
sure all the messaging all the emotional
stuff was clear and was really landing
of course we're always going for better
jokes and having this amazing cast and
guys like jim carrey and of course ben
schwartz with what he does with sonic
he's always looking for the best version
of a joke or a delivery so everyone
cares so much everyone wants to get to
get it right and to make fans and
audiences just uh thrilled with with the
movie we made um so yeah it it's uh uh
it just everyone works really hard did
you end up with a lot of uh deleted
scenes
uh there's there is uh uh some that i
love and just for one reason or another
we're we're not able to uh to sort of
make the final cut um i i have i have no
doubt that paramount's gonna be looking
for a way to release some of those
because who doesn't love uh deleted
scenes i mean they're they're uh there's
some really wonderful robotic stone
interactions that relationship is so
hilarious and lee majoob and and jim
carrey are just absolutely uh uh just
magical together so hopefully we'll get
some of those out and fans can enjoy
them i would like to see them so yes
please do that um without getting into
spoilers the ending of the film has a
like a post credits or an after you know
like middle of credits type scene uh i'm
just curious how how long did you decide
or how did you figure out what you
wanted to put there
i i i have my favorite my list of of
characters and and that uh for for many
reasons uh which i can't really go into
was the top of the list fortunately
everybody else on our side the
filmmaking side sega paramount uh our
producers everyone kind of felt the same
way it was like oh yeah that's that's
what we got to do so that that sort of
clicked from early on and and i'm so i'm
so excited about people seeing it uh
yeah was there did you come close to
another was it always that character
uh it was always that character
how does it work with um you know with a
film like this where you have the studio
and you have sega how much are they sort
of
in the weeds and sort of in there
figuring out like all the things you
want to do and how much about like the
balance of creative freedom versus what
the studios kind of want
oh it's they're great partners i mean we
were given a a a wonderful amount of
latitude after the first film to go off
to outline to kind of identify the broad
strokes of the story the character
development character arcs uh come back
pitch them on both sides in paramount
and sega uh and sort of just uh continue
to sort of work through the ideas with
them but we get a tremendous amount of
freedom but at the same time we're
obviously so respectful of sega's
characters it's so important that they
have a voice in the room and and and
they i mean have so much knowledge and
so much history of these characters
they're a wonderful resource they always
keep us on track in terms of just making
sure that that we're we're
uh giving fans the uh the the characters
the versions of the characters that they
know and love so it really is a team
effort uh and i'm so proud of of the the
film we made and sort of the result of
all that collaboration
i know that um they're doing like that
knuckles live action series and i would
imagine that they're going to explore
other options with the popularity of
these movies um are you you mentioned
you're not involved in these things is
it something that you want to be
involved with are you
you know what i mean oh i mean i i i
love these characters i love this movie
universe that we've built uh i think
there's so many exciting things possible
in the future uh again right now it's
just um so right now it's all about the
adrenaline of finally getting to share
this movie that we've been working on
for the last two years uh with audiences
i think they're gonna have such an
amazing time but yeah it's the the best
uh the best possible outcome would be to
get to tell more stories and to continue
like with knuckles i mean such an
incredible character i think fans are
going to just walk out of this movie
wanting more of him like immediately uh
and so yeah i mean it would be uh it'd
be wonderful to be part of that planning
on that note i gotta go i'm just gonna
say congrats and uh it's really hard to
do what you did and you did it thanks
steve i wish you nothing but the best
appreciate it man take care
you